Vermont senator Bernie Sanders won his
state's Democratic primary last night
but he will run as an independent for
re-election in November he is with us
good morning senator with your tone
well you what do you think about this
history in the gubernatorial race
Christine how Quist the first
transgender I think it says that didn't
Vermont we looked at the ideas that
people have not their sexual orientation
I hope that that concept is spreading
all over the country I think it is
something it's a good thing tell me
about the Democratic Party right now the
ideas that are winning the day some of
your candidates at once some of them
have lost what's happening in the
Democrat think two things are happening
John number one the ideas that we have
been fighting for ideas that I think
makes sense to the needs of working
families I think those ideas are
spreading all over the country and have
more and more support you look at the
issues like Medicare for all should we
end the embarrassment of being the only
major country on earth not to guarantee
health care to all people poll after
poll says yeah we should move in that
direction should we give tax breaks to
billionaires which is what Trump wants
what demand that the wealthy and large
corporations start paying their fair
share of taxes that is what the American
people want should we move toward
raising the minimum wage now a
starvation wage of seven and a quarter
now - fifteen bucks an hour that's what
the American people want so what I'm
saying John is all across this country
people are saying we want a government
that represents all of us not just the
billionaire class and wealthy campaign
contributors tell me about the
Democratic Party and how they balance
these two things they've got a win in
2018 in districts where the idea of
Medicare for all and the cost of that is
a little too much for maybe the voters
in those suburban swing districts the
idea of free college they hear the
numbers racking up in terms of the
federal deficit on the other hand you
talk about this energy inside the
Democratic Party so how does the
Democratic Party balance those two
things I think what is happening is
there is a whole lot of energy and I
think what you're seeing all across this
country is not only progressives winning
and losing occasionally but what you are
seeing is people running for office for
the first time you're seeing women
people of color young people getting
involved in politics and frankly a way
that we have not seen for a long long
time I think that's good for America I
think that's good for the Democratic
Party four years ago let me say this in
the midterm election
we have the lowest voter turnout in 70
years what the Democrats got to do is
excite people get young people working
people to the polls if they do that I
think we're gonna do just fine well we
recently good I was just gonna ask you
about leadership because one target for
the Republicans and for the president
obviously is Nancy Pelosi even some
Democrats say that she needs to go her
responses they come after me because I'm
effective is she an effective leader
yeah I think Nancy has done a good job
let me say which he may not say I think
it's also the fact that she's a woman I
think they have demonized that the
Republican Party is bankrupt
intellectually they are not going to
campaign on their views of giving tax
breaks to billionaires and cutting
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid so
they have to come up with some demon I
guess their demon now is Nancy Pelosi
well we recently talked about leadership
we recently asked a panel Millennials
which you you are very popular with the
Millennials who they think is a
Democratic leader who is a party leader
and they couldn't come up with an answer
does that concern you or surprise you no
it doesn't concern me look I think at
the end of the day we are 50 states in
this country and what gratifies me very
very much as somebody was gone around
this country who has been to state after
state trying to see that we can't elect
progressive Democrats is I am seeing an
energy level that I have not seen before
so I'm less worried about people on top
than I or that I am about seeing young
people and working people get involved
and that is happening l-let me ask you a
quick question what those young people
democratic socialism is appealing to
some of them who are also might be
interested in the Democratic Party the
idea of socialism versus capitalism does
that conversation need to be more in the
present in the for the medium makes a
bigger deal of it than it should look at
the issues should every American have
health care as a right at a time when we
spend twice as much per capita on health
care as any other country how the
highest prices in the world for
prescription drugs and 30 million people
have no health insurance that is a
disastrous system of course we need to
move to Medicare for all should at a
time we're in a competitive global
economy we make public colleges and
universities tuition-free the answer is
yes look at the issues out there but I
will also say this John I think that
there is growing resentment not only
among young people who in many cases are
gonna have a lowest
of living than their parents I think
that there is an understanding or
something fundamentally immoral and
wrong that a nation which we have three
people who own more wealth than the
bottom half of the American people that
does not make sense and of course the
response from many as we like the ideas
how do we pay for them this conversation
of course will continue but we've run
out of time senator thank you for
joining us